hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm Melea
success Alysia six dusky sushi registers
habit there we go now we're in the
center perfect Alicia
you may recognize her if you've been at
on this channel for ever since the
beginning actually the first the first
time we ever tried filming like ever
tried took us six hours to set up
she was waiting with a simple time and
we did nothing with the footage but
she's back now she's Veronica's sister
she's really cool man she's a cool Cal
Cal yeah cow cow yeah you can catch her
on she's one of the stars of east los
eyes she has a reoccurring on one about
foster kids the Fosters and what else oh
and you're in a competition what you
talk about that competition here it's a
xxx latina magazine 30 under 30 I am
nominated to be one of those 30 so yeah
100 a promotion I'm all about
self-promotion anyways cuz I would like
the votes and we're gonna check out the
trailer for Jem and the Holograms today
the trailer number two I did not see
part one trailer did you no no all right
let's find out what this is about
play okay what are you working on well
I'm working on my greatest creation I
probably shall see it
when you're a little older okay okay
have you ever wanted a secret identity
oh my god your internet famous looks
like the second best thing to being
actually famous on your camera she must
be doing reactions
Jen this is exactly the artist that
Starlight has been looking for it was a
little help of course my transition
number one trending topic on Twitter
there are some voices that are too
special to keep hidden because of your
father's words so there we were headed
towards the unknown and this is where it
gets weird
whoa they said your dad's invention do
not work exactly
where you go from here that's up to you
you'll be totally solo contract and back
smile and most important looked like
you're having fun but don't really have
fun got it
let me explain what's been going on
explain what you want to go solo that's
what family's supposed to act the
version of me that they want doesn't
exist you're in the habit the concerts
going as planned
all right let's see what you're trying
to me time with family with the ones you
love most there's nothing more valuable
than that even the odds seem impossible
you need to trust the people you're
closest to
showtimes indeed
and my heart you'll always be my job
well it's corny has a really deep
sentimental movie I mean the first part
time being like like sassy and sexy and
cool why is there a robot in this movie
yeah there was no point for the robot
yeah
it's like Oh YouTube sensation Twitter
followers internet sensation getting a
burger and then there's a robot and then
forget about the robot for a while and
then there's a robot against the robot
aspect looked the most unique out of all
of it
but at the same time it seems out of
place like it belongs in a different
movie this movie seems like a ripoff of
a lot of things Devil Wears Prada meets
Hannah Montana meets Hugo that's what I
would say yeah yeah it's good right it's
good it's called intellect yeah
developed it over time the opening scene
reminded me of something of a movie it
was like oh my I was like wait a second
I've seen this like the little kid
asking what the what he's working on
yeah if anybody knows what that first
scene reminds you of make a comment
below and she will tell you if yes that
was the one wait you said you recognize
someone in the movie yes oh yes she's
the one with the turquoise hair she's
the Asian one yeah she's awesome
she's amazing she's scary and I want to
go watch this movie because of her she's
intense but she's amazing she's like so
the sweetest girl she is I feel like
she'll like rip my balls off her so
really good because she's a really tough
girl but she's like sweet oh okay
I'd like to meet you Haley I'd like to
meet you I've heard of Jim in the
Holograms
okay yes it was a cartoon I mean looking
at that footage of the eighties cartoon
it made me go like I don't feel like
this movie is capturing that spirit at
all like this looks like a modern-day
take on it but looks like a ripoff of a
lot of other stories looks kind of
generic this is my opinion yeah I could
see how it appeals to a female
demographic is such as yourself right I
mean I think that you would still go
watch it secretly just because of the
YouTube thing just secretly I might just
go for fun because I like it yeah you
know he's gonna go watch this and he's
gonna get all the tips and get more
followers yeah Jem and the Holograms
before me I'm successful on YouTube yeah
you gotta watch the film mm-hm
it just feels rather generic as opposed
to like why remake this other than just
the brand name you know it's like why
not try to capture the actual spirit
well the person who made it was
obviously loved the Jem and the
Holograms let's hope and they wanted to
make it because I don't know what you do
when you're trying to get over your
childhood just you know make art and
then put it out there for the world to
see so you can get better yeah I think I
think you're the only one who's gonna
get such a deep interpretation from
history yeah this is a passion beat so
this director he's done a lot of music
related stuff you know documentaries on
music the step-up films or whatever so
he's done a lot of music related stuff
so maybe he can capture it but I feel
like if they were to honor kind of the
craziness of the cartoon I feel like
they could have done that with modern
day sure but even cat needed even more
vibrant and a little bit more ecstatic
and stuff rather than I feel like it's
holding back in some ways I'm sure it's
gonna be fun for the younger generation
and we need more robots
yes if we can get that robot in there
most of the film it would be good anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the channel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects there are several
things for Alicia that you can check out
she's on Hulu Z slows hi is one of the
stars she has a reoccurring on the
Fosters and for latina comm the actual
domain is latina comm 30 under 30 vote
for her there's a bunch of Canada
nominated she's nominated one of most
talented Latinas so vote for her there's
a link in the description box and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter me I'm buying a periscope her on
snapchat what is it Lexi o Meneses I'm a
big fan of the chairman I love to watch
your reactions to the videos you remind
me of myself
both our girlfriends are tens oh there
are tens like you have a 10 year old
girl my girlfriend's I'm 10 years old
and I also have a weird man crush for
Ryan girl Ryan Gosling my girlfriend
says I'm crazy you're not crazy I like
the dynamic of your videos of the way
you guys interact with each other PS I
don't know your real name but I bet it's
not worse than mine seriously Alexi oh
you look pronouncing it sounds bad in
any language
Alexi Oh Alejo Alejo oh that's a type of
um you're gonna have to help me out here
to remember what this is but that is a
type of strange sex maneuver isn't it
how could I help you with that I virgin
lies no I mean aleyhi oh that's when you
are that's no that's when you're going
to the bathroom no I don't want to hear
it the only number two while you're
going numbers - you're performing oral
sex
oh wow that is disgusting I am I am NOT
I'm never coming to your show again you
want to be the first one